mark scott congratulations you guys have
made it to the third and final round of
this competition now we're asking you to
go back to your home forges and recreate
this iconic weapon from history
the dousage yes
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days good luck
[Music]
here we are ready to kill it i want to
have this blade
shaped and ready for heat treat if i
could heat treat on the end of day one
i'll be
really good in line right now i am going
to start
trying to grind a little bit of taper in
this blade and make sure that fuller
sets in as deep as i can get it
kind of thinned it out a little bit i
didn't want to grind too much before
heat treat
that looks rad i like that a lot once i
got that thing
rough to shape and got the bend in with
my little whacking method it was time to
just heat treat it
all right boys and girls
yeah she's nice and straight oh yeah
it's a hard blade so can't stress how
happy i am actually inside right now
[Music]
it's day one i'm back in emporia kansas
and i'm making a dousage
the plan for day one is to get the blade
forged out thermal cycle
and then hardened there is a lot put
into the handle work so i'm wanting to
get my forging done as quick as possible
i always like to forge thick grind thin
and not have to worry about warps
one of the hardest parts is done getting
your tang done now just put a point on
it
hammer the bevels in
at this point i got the blade forged out
i get it down into the oil
yeah baby that's a good sign right there
no warps nice and straight
it is a huge relief it's like when you
have to poop and then you finally get to
go it's just one of the best feelings
ever
beginning of day three i'm feeling
spunky ready to get going let's get to
work
today is going to be making that clam
shell guard so i have
chunks of lead that i use for casting
and so i'm going to use that lid i think
it'll absorb that steel a little bit
better
the first thing i do is make myself a
die with rounded edges and around nose
i'm just gonna smash into it
that's gonna turn out pretty nice
i was hitting it with the ball peen
hammer and realized that i actually
liked the hammer look into the sled
block a lot better so i just ran with it
dude that thing's fitting awesome end of
day three got a lot more done than i
anticipated so things are cruising along
pretty good
start out on day four and the last part
of the guard i have to make is the clam
shell guard
so i just laid it out on a piece of
sheet metal cut it out and just
started working it from there once i get
the lines put in the clam shell
i stick it in the forge and i actually
start curving it to the shape of my fist
damn that's hot it's really important to
get it
snug enough to actually work properly
and protect your fist
but also it's not so tight that it's
just digging into your hand
guard dung final assembly that's what
i'm going to be working on now
it is the end of day four and i'm
feeling great
because i finished my sword and it looks
good
beginning of day four all i got to do is
make sure this thing's sharp
let's slice some fruit up and let's see
this thing work
this thing is razor sharp the sword
feels great for me
so i'm hoping it's the same for somebody
knows how to use one it tastes good too
all right blazbizz welcome to the keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
the european will do i'll take your
weapon
deliver some slashes of thrust on this
big carcass
scott you're up first you ready for this
oh yeah let's do this
i am super excited to see doug chop up a
pig with my blade i run my mouth all the
time like i can do that i can do that so
now is the time to see if i can really
walk the walk because i know i can talk
the talk
all right scott first up it is
light the balance really allows for
velocity and recovery with this blade
and most importantly it will kill yeah
all right mark your turns are you ready
heck yeah let's do this
i'm ready to see my sword destroy cut
slice but i want to see the insides of
that pig
you're just hanging there like chewing
gum all right mark talk about your blade
here
it's beautiful in its creation the edge
is sharp
i was quite amazed with the cuts i was
surprised that it cut that deeply
the one thing though is that that guard
right there there rubs on my knuckle
not bad but it does rub on the knuckle
despite that
it will kill yes
[Music]
all right gentlemen welcome to the
strength test the whiskey barrel chop
yeah now to test the strength and
overall construction of your swords i
will be swinging into these whiskey
barrels
so scott you're up first you ready for
this oh yeah all right
oh first off scott this thing
is still a razor blade on its entire
length
except for right there you did take a
bit of a roll there
and a very small chip but beautiful
craftsmanship
super light fast blade and very strong
nicely done thank you mark you're up
next are you ready for this
smash them okay
here she goes
all right mark got an edge all the way
across this thing yes
he didn't lose a bit the only issue i
have with this weapon at all
as doug said my knuckle
rides right there on the inside of the
guard it's not chewing my hand up
but there is contact right there where i
don't necessarily want it
it's a beautiful weapon it's strong
nicely done thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the four filler slice
these pillars are wrapped in different
materials foam leather canvas
and silk scotch here first ready for
this oh yeah
all right scott's talking about your
weapon here it is light every cut
it cuts nicely overall sir
it will cut thank you all right mark on
to your shiny sword you ready for this
slice and dice
[Music]
all right mark's talking about your
blade here that's a cutter right there
you can feel the weight of the power
with your slashes with this
on the leather it did cut it's just
because the thicker kind of blade that
you have here to cut all the way through
but overall sir it'll cut
mark scott both of you guys turned in
incredibly competitive
blades however the judges have completed
their deliberation they've made their
final decision
our new forged and fire champion is
scott congratulations mark
unfortunately the judges have decided
that your blade doesn't make the cut
mark we have a competition with two
blades that perform as amazingly as your
two blades do
it comes down to judging the
craftsmanship of the blade your blade
rubbed our knuckles and for that small
reason we're letting you go
understand mark please surrender your
blade
i'm bummed that i lost but i'm very
proud of myself from what i've
accomplished
that was a fine piece man going home
because my guard was rubbing the judge's
knuckles just a slight bit
that little teeny tiny detail you live
and you learned
mark is an amazing blade smith there
wasn't mark telling me i can do this i
got this
good job buddy i'd be the one going home
i really hope i made my kids proud of
this
and the world gets to see what cool
beans nice gets to do
well scott in one of our tightest
competitions to date you've become the
forest and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job thank
you thank you
i won baby yes this ranks up there with
getting married having children oh yeah
i'm a fortune fire champion too by the
way
what's next for me um get my 10 grand in
one so i can roll around in it you know
normal stuff you know what normal
champions do
you